personalidad va a estar explorando el
cráter g0 y los depósitos de un delta y
décima límite como el delta de en el
amazonas o en el mississippi y esos
depósitos tienen son muy buenos para
preservar un material orgánico entonces
vamos recoger esas muestras y el rover
los va a poner en un tubo y les va a
salvar y depositar en una área especial
con nuestro después viene otra misión
que se llama martes tiempo de richard al
retorno de muestras de marte y eso es
una campaña de dos misiones que va a
aterrizar un lander con un cohete recoge
con un pequeño rover esas muestras las
pone del cohete y las lanza de regreso a
un satélite que va a estar esperando la
recoge y las trae a la tierra entonces
eso va a pasar en los 2030
también le preguntamos al científico
planetario de la nasa jorge núñez y esta
misión representa un paso para
conquistar marte y esto fue lo que nos
dijo con esta misión esto estamos
ensayando muchas de las tecnologías que
nos va a ayudar a poder hacer la primera
exploración de marte con los humanos
entonces por ejemplo unas de las
tecnologías se llama stranger navigation
que éste es de navegación de relativa
del terreno que es básicamente imagínate
como google maps pero para dentro de la
nave espacial entonces tiene la imagen
de la superficie con las áreas de
peligro y va a comparar las imágenes
cuando el rover estuvo cayendo mirando a
comparar y eso de tecnología nos deja
aterrizar con más precisión que se ha
podido antes la otra tecnología es que
va a tener un instrumento que se llama
marc sí y ese instrumento recoge la
atmósfera de marte y la convierte en
oxígeno y eso esta tecnología nos va a
ayudar utilizar los recursos locales en
marte que eventualmente se pueblos esto
se pueden utilizar por ejemplo para
generar no sólo oxígeno para respirar
pero también para combustible para las
mascotas